Now we'll use Green's Rhythm
For solving some linear yojas.
But, before showing the example I was one
I want to make clear about Green's theorem.
In the examples we have seen before, we used such a size,
And the interior of the shape is always running in us
The road was left.
For all the examples I have turned clockwise and so on
The size was always on our left-- that is, if we imagine it
That's the way we are walking in that direction, but the size will always remain on our left.
And in that case we can use Green's theorem.
So, if we want to find linear yoga in this way,
A closed linear yoga, but we marked him in this way
Can do
In some textbooks, it is f f (dot) of c
The way is also marked. It actually indicates the size of the letter R